oh
vous avez probablement vécu lors d'un
dîner une dégustation de vins ces
moments suspendus ou surpris et
intrigués votre palais se délecte d'une
bouchée d'une gorgée et votre esprit
questionne il ya dans ce plat dans ce
vin quelque chose que je connais et tu
n'arrives pas à identifier
à cet instant précis votre voisin se met
à commenter avec virtuosité
moi je dirais du fruit fruit mûr plus
tôt confie d'état l'interet velouté ce
voisin eva plein de sensations qui vous
disent plus ou moins quelque chose
confie bizarre mais fruité oui il a dit
mangue
j'aurais plutôt dit abricots ce voisin
évoque des sensations qui vous semblent
difficiles à sentir par vous même vous
dites c'est un expert moi je ne suis pas
capable de goûter comme lui à cet
instant précis dans votre esprit
ce voisin ce pourrait être moi je suis
un expert du goût vu de loin
je travaille dans une école de cuisine
nous anime de la recherche
je goûte beaucoup j'organise des
ateliers de créativité culinaire des
dégustations je forme des dégustateurs
goûter manger est essentiel de levie
exprimer ce que l'on ressent et pourtant
souvent complexe le goût est assez
personnel
nous avons tous des préférences les
différences culturelles
il est pourtant beaucoup plus subjectif
que vous ne l'imaginez
nous allons en faire l'expérience tous
ensemble je vous propose de prendre la
petite enveloppe bleue qui est caché
collé sous les sièges de votre fauteuil
il est à l'intérieur une petite
languette blanche à 3 et si vous le
voulez bien seulement à 3 vous avez la
mettre sur votre langue
vous êtes près 1 2 3 on y va ce qu'ils
ressentent quelque chose lever la main
s'il vous plaît les autres regarder le
visage de votre voisin vous êtes
sûrement surpris parce que vous vous ne
sentez rien et pourtant pourtant vous
venez de goûter exactement la même chose
qu'eux et celui qui a senti la mer peut
très bien passer lui à côté d'un goût de
bouchon ou de réglisse chacun sa
perception
nous avons tous une combinaison
génétique différentes
c'est une particularité du goût et de
l'odorat ses 200 sont d'ailleurs
intimement lié ce sont les sens
chimiques 80% de notre goût et de
l'odorat des odeurs dans notre bouche
ce bleu certains le voient plutôt vers
on l'appelle parfois turquoise jamais
rouge pour le goût et l'odorat
il est tout à fait possible que
quelqu'un gouttes vert quand quelqu'un
d'autres goûtent rouge alors se mettre
d'accord pose une question ambiguë et
difficile comment puis-je parler avec
mon voisin comment puis-je nommer les
choses que je ne ressens pas comme lui
d'un côté la science dit il n'a pas de
mot pour parler du goût puisque nous
sommes tous différents et de l'autre la
société les gens les professionnels un
clame démodé lexique des discours des
histoires c'est exactement ici que se
trouve le défi intellectuel et pratique
qui m'anime depuis de nombreuses années
nous nous sommes uniques vous êtes
unique
pour autant est-ce que nous sommes
libres dans mes ateliers
je fais une expérience assez souvent qui
vous fait penser à votre voisin de tout
à l'heure vous savez celui qui disait du
fruit
les fruits mûrs etc je fais je prends un
vin blanc que je fais goûter avec un vin
que j'ai coloré en rouge quand les
participants qui déguste à leur insu
gouttes ce vin blanc ils le décrivent
poire acacias fleurs blanches quand ils
goûtent experts aux novices le vin
coloré en rouge
il y trouve des notes de cerises de
cassis de fruits rouges
etonnant non autre expérience que vous
pouvez faire chez vous d'ailleurs il
s'agit de croiser les étiquettes de 2,20
un grand château avec un petit château
par exemple les novices comme les
experts ne perçoivent pas toujours la
version ils jugent bien souvent le vin
pareti qui l'étiquette individuellement
les experts et les connaisseurs sont
faillibles
ils le savent il ne s'agit pas de les
discréditer
il s'agit de vous libérer vous êtes tous
potentiellement des dégustateurs
compétents c'est une question de
décision de motivation d'entraînement
bien sûr vous avez rapidement pouvoir
développer votre pouvoir de dégustateurs
pourquoi goûtons nous d'ailleurs pas
seulement pour évaluer un vin ou un plat
ou faire impression auprès de notre
voisin nous goûtons 1 pour survivre
l'homo sapiens apprenait à détecter un
goût dangereux et puis les vite et
ensuite si ce qui nous reste en réflexe
quand nous hésitons à goûter et nous
taton du bout de la langue l'aliment
nous goûtons 2 pour nous identifier à
l'aliment pas seulement l'identifier
mais nous identifier à l'aliment si je
mangeais du sanglier ou du lion c'était
pour être courageux si je bois du coca
quand je suis enfant c'est près de cool
comme les copains si je vois de l'icca m
du margaux château margaux parce que je
mérite mais j'en ai le droit d'ailleurs
goûté manger c'est à incorporer
littéralement je suis ce que je mange
est ce que cela représente goûtez donc
me permet de me distinguer ces deux
raisons existent depuis que l'homme vit
en société
aujourd'hui devant mon assiette ou en
levant son verre
si je sais que je ne vais pas
d'emprisonner et si je pense un instant
que je n'ai pas besoin de me rassurer
sur qui je suis à travers ce que je
mange ou ce que je bois je vais à leur
pouvoir être optimiste
dégoûté de deux façons vraiment
intéressante
la dégustation augmenter et une
dégustation plus sensibles au goût des
autres passons à la dégustation augmenté
pas augmenté par un serveur informatique
planqué dans un
stockés dans une armoire augmenté par
vous même en relation vraie avec les
autres et en pleine conscience
aujourd'hui on peut tout manger des yeux
online on peut tout visionner tout
écouter pour à peu près 0 euros et
pourtant vous continuez à aller au
théâtre au concert au tedx dans les fan
zone continue à les restaurants sur les
marchés à faire des pique niques géants
le virtuel ne tue pas mon besoin de réel
au contraire il lui demande et de nous
demande nous appelle des expériences
plus intense plus riches
vous allez voir vous allez pouvoir vous
même créer votre contexte avec vos
sensations ici même fermé les yeux
imaginez stimuler vos compétences
immédiate convoqué vos souvenirs avec
une simple pomme
comparez votre fruit à d'autres pommes
la dernière croquer celle de votre
démarche est celle de votre enfance
le goût de la pomme n'est pas dans la
pomme et votre cerveau va stimuler vos
papiers pour vous seul parce que vous
seul savait à quelle sensation et à
quelle image vous associer cette pomme
avec des mots ou sans on peut bien sûr
vous aider à trouver vos mots la méthode
on ne peut pas les choisir à votre place
augmenter l'expérience autour d'un plat
partager l'intention d'une création
c'est aussi une des préoccupations des
chefs et des professionnels des métiers
de bouche
dilemme entre le goût du chef le goût du
client et le goût de ceux qui en parlent
pour eux se crée un triangle amoureux où
la communication est difficile
l'acidité peut y être pour le chef
associé à la groseille au la pomme verte
pour le serveur et la grume pour le
premier client du jour chacun a une
perception
ça fait 3 perception même à partager et
à goûter ensemble
et je suis sûr que vous aussi vous avez
des contextes gustatif en tête que vous
pouvez partager
il ya cependant des contextes plus
difficiles et des aliments qui divise
fortement le plus grand par exemple le
lait fermenté les notes animales
prenez un écossais qui rencontre un
auvergnat
le premier amène du haggis c'est de la
panse de brebis farcie et le second des
tripes et si au lieu de vente et ferment
leurs traditions gastronomiques
ils partagent les produits les
ingrédients les sensations alors ils
goûtent ensemble et s'apprivoisent il
lève les préjugés les barrières
culturelles et apprendre apprennent à
manger davantage ensemble
je suis sûr que vous aussi vous avez des
enfants et que vous cherchez improvise
avec vos enfants pour le goût c'est pas
toujours facile avec eux vous pouvez
avec eux les les aider par le jeu par la
découverte par le partage en goûtant
avec eux en mangeant avec eux ne
renoncez pas trop vite surtout répéter
ça prend parfois du temps
moi même je n'ai pas mangé de la de
poissons jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans aucun
poisson même pas nés même enfilé une
histoire d'art est mal avalé arrive un
jour à l'ami de la famille qui cuisinent
une brandade de morue
je la prends pour un gratin elle a
ouvert mon goût tous les poissons pour
toujours j'ai goûté
j'ai aimé j'ai adoré et son goût est
ouvert définitivement la cuisine bien
sûr nous aide
elle nous aide à mettre des ingrédients
parfois bizarres dans la casserole pour
en faire la culture et du plaisir
la prochaine fois que vous irez au
restaurant monsieur j'espère que vous
goûterez un petit peu différemment en
vous ouvrant davantage à un plat que
vous n'avez pas l'habitude de commenter
et vous madame la prochaine fois que
vous irez chez quelqu'un que vous
connaissez peu ou pas peut-être qui sait
vous aurez cette envie de vous ouvrir
davantage de nourriture des autres et
vous tous envie de goûter les aliments
de demain une fois que vous serez
tranquille chez vous rien qu'avec une
pomme ou un carré de chocolat
prenez un instant pour vous même
prenez le temps de goûter notez vos
sensations sur un carnet ou bien dans
votre tête ou rien de tout cela au
papier ils font de vous un être unique
et vous êtes maître en votre palais